les questions que l'on se pose sur sur
les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle ne se limit pas seulement
à leur programme leur parcours leur
histoire nous renseignent aussi sur
l'homme ou la femme politique justement
nous nous sommes intéressés aux années
de jeunesse des candidats nous débutons
cette série par le portrait de François
baayerou d'anciens profs d'anciens
copains se sont confiés à Luc
laguinboucher et Marc dou c'était pas un
toutou mais c'était pas un
révolutionnaire il avait un petit peu
l'âme d'un menur plutôt turbulent il
était intellectuellement sportif voilà
c'était ça
François difficile à résumer le jeune
François beayrou il fait son secondaire
au lycée public de Naille dans les
Pyrénées Atlantique sa scolarité est
plutôt tranquille c'était vraiment
l'élève normal pas en pâté pas en plâé
pas impossible pas impi je dis pas que
c'était le personnage du lycée c'est pas
vrai c'est pas vrai mais c'était un
homme un peu à part voilà un peu à part
mais qui se fondait dans la masse avous
c'était il était comme nous c'était un
garçon qui faisait plein de bêtises il
était très souvent puni à l'école hein
parce qu'il était trop agité parce qu'il
discutait parce qu'il revendiquait et
très souvent il était collé le jeudi
j'étais un élève dissipé et peu
travailleur je sais pas si je dois
avouer ça à la caméra j'ai pas le
souvenir d'avoir fait mes devoirs jamais
le je n'ai jamais fait de mes devoirs de
toute ma scolarité je crois que c'était
quand même une cocaterie parce que les
devoirs étaient contrôlés les devoirs
était relevé Baayou avait de bonnes
notes voire très bonnes notes donc je ne
vois pas comment il pouvait obtenir ces
notes sans faire ses devoir sur les
terres béarnaises François Baayou dénote
différent il est jusque dans sa manière
de parler il bégille un défaut
desélocution dont il viendra à bout bien
des années plus tard on l'a appelé
Pintin et on l'a appelé aussitintin
parce qu'il avait une petite il était il
avait une petite hupette devant et on
l'appelait SHX avec son son bégément il
avait énormément de mal à dire
Shakespeare et donc B ch SH SH ça se
bousculait et ça lui est resté il avait
tellement d'idées en même temps qu'il
voulait les formuler toutes ensemble et
elle se elle se
bagarrait à la à la barrière de ses
dents comme dit
Homère il est curieux de tout lit
beaucoup y compris la presse la
politique comme la marche du monde
l'intéresse à 12 ans il en parle déjà
avec enthousiasme
le 22 novembre
63 j'entrai au lycée dans la cour à 2h
de l'après-midi et je vois ce jeune
garçon ce presque gamin blondiné courir
vers moi à travers la cour et me dire
monsieur monsieur vous avez appris la
nouvelle dis non quelle nouvelle vous ne
savez pas Kennedy vient d'être assassiné
ça vraiment c'est dans mon esprit c'est
devant la salle d'études on était en
rang et lui il nous parlait politique il
nous disait voilà il y a Luc nuet il y
avait je sa plus barbu il y avait des
des gens de ce style en 65 et on se
demandait vraiment mais pourquoi est-ce
qu'il nous parle de
ça l'année du bac au mois de mai éclate
les événements en 1968 non seulement il
était assis sur les tables mais il était
debout sur les tables politiquement
j'étais là ni du côté du pouvoir c'était
le golisme
immobilier les affaires le on avait
l'impression les abus l'information
verrouillée
ni l'union de la gauche à cause de ce
qui se passait de l'autre côté du rideau
de fer à l'automne 68 bac en poche
François Baou part à bordeau et décroche
une agrégation de lettrre classique
passionné de politique mais sans enfer
il s'engagera plus tard au centre
évidemment